you recently had one of your blog posts
on indiewire
and someone commented back and said hey
you know congratulations diane but
don't you want to just be the writer
director
why come in as a producer don't you want
just the creative aspect
and not more and you had a wonderful
intelligent response to that well i've
just had a massive paradigm shift for
myself over the last couple years when
we did obsolidia i
did not take a producer's credit on the
movie because i was
really off the thought i yeah i remember
talking to you about i said i don't want
to be a producer like i want to write
and i want to direct and i do not want
to produce movies um
but what i've realized uh now my second
film
i'm not a producer on it at all and it
really has been a situation where i am
like
i am just the writer director and i
really realized actually it's a
privilege and an honor to be a producer
a movie then i don't think i'll ever
make a movie again without being a
producer
like on one hand i think you have to
take responsibility for your work and i
think like right now and certainly
obsolete would never have got made had i
just taken the view of like somebody
else is going to do it all
you know when you have a creative idea
and
you want to make something happen you
have to make it happen
you know and that's what producers do
and i think you know especially for your
first film the idea that someone's going
to come along and do it all for
you is um an insane dream you know
so i think like certainly for your first
film you're gonna have to like roll up
your sleeves and make it happen
uh and then thereafter i feel like
actually i've realized
it's just an honor it's like i mean
having a making a film is really like
having a child in a certain way
and you want to be the best parent you
can and really like help that child
flourish and do well
and get out in the world and meet the
people that it should meet
and i honestly think like as the creator
of it
you're like the person like most savvy
or most knowledgeable really of what
that
is you know i look at someone like shane
karat who did upstream color
a couple years ago and i think his model
is terrific of how he distributed his
movie
and produced it and sort of did
everything because in his marketing i
mean he understood his film
in a way that no distributor really
would have and certainly probably even
other producer you know like a producer
and his vision for the film then you
know permeated everything in the way
that it was released
into the world and i just think like
actually for me now i find that more
exciting as a challenge right
rather than being like no i'm just the
writer and director and you guys can
figure out the marketing and you can
figure out this and you can figure out
that
i feel like actually no i want to be a
part of all those discussions and it's
not to say that i'll do everything by
myself
you know like i work with a producer
chris and i you know work with other
producers absolutely but i definitely
want to be
on the producer's table as well for
every film that i do from now on and i
think it's
i think it's really an honor and a
privilege to be there
you know um we were lucky with obsolete
though because we got
we met matt medlen who was the producer
i did a lot of physical stuff producing
wise and
and kind of logistical stuff but he
really did the nuts and bolts
of the organizational skills of getting
it from a to b
to c and the contracts and dealing with
the union and he did
that he did that and we met him
at a very interesting time in his career
where he was
shifting from low really micro budget
independent films to
an upper echelon of independent films
and he's gone on to make you know you
know million dollar
movies now since then but um
we will go back to that model
of working with somebody at that level
again
hopefully matt but if not him somebody
else
like him like-minded because the
power now is in the hands of the
filmmakers to actually try and monetize
their work
at an independent level social media
wise and the audience
that they can build in that platform
and use that in order to be able to
monetize their ideas and their work so
that they can continue
to work as an artist further down the
line and
you know maybe somewhere along the way
if they get hit up by
a studio to do something then you know
they have that option as well but at the
same time they're
able to continue to monetize their work
so that they can make
a living at the work that they're doing
and
be able to you know be creative so that
that's one of the things that we're
looking at now again going back
from what diana's just experienced to
the older model
and then using the platforms that are
available today to be able to
you know put that product out there